Google parent company alphabet is the
latest tech giant to trim thousands of
jobs the company announced its slashing
six percent of its Workforce Google's
largest ever round of layoffs follows
recent cuts by Microsoft Amazon and meta
the parent company of Facebook Michael
George has been following the tech trim
Michael good morning Michelle good
morning now some experts call this a
correction tech companies boom during
the pandemic over hired and now they
have to adjust to a post-pandemic
economy but really there's no way to
spend this as positive more than ten
thousand people are suddenly finding
themselves unemployed
alphabet the parent company of Google is
cutting 12 000 jobs about six percent of
its Workforce in an email the company's
CEO wrote over the past two years we've
seen periods of dramatic growth to match
and fuel that growth we hired for a
different economic reality than the one
we face today the belt tightening at
Google follows other recent Tech sector
job Cuts Microsoft announced earlier
this week it's laying off ten thousand
workers or nearly five percent of its
Workforce Amazon has said it's cutting
18 000 jobs and meta the parent company
of Facebook announced it's laying off
eleven thousand positions I think that
many companies are
right sizing their their staff many tech
companies went on a pandemic hiring
spree because of increased demand for
their products as millions of people
worked remotely by late last year
Google's parent company alphabet said it
had nearly 187
000 employees on the books it is pretty
easy for most companies to cut 10 to 15
percent of their employee base right now
economists say what's happening in Tech
is so far an exception in the labor
market the overall labor market has been
remarkably resilient the latest data we
have through December suggested it is
holding up despite higher interest rates
Isaac Del Rosario is a recently laid off
software engineer in Seattle I've been
in the interview hunt for about four
months now Del Rosario is finding job
openings by looking outside of the big
Tech Giants surprisingly I've been able
to get interviews from more like smaller
startups for newly out of work software
Engineers a job search beyond the big
name companies may be the way to go and
even with the new downsizing many of the
big tech companies are still bigger than
they were before the pandemic
now laid off Google workers will get a
severance package of 16 weeks salary
plus two weeks for every year at the
company and it's important to note
despite the massive layoffs in Tech
overall the nation's unemployment rate
last month was 3.5 percent that's a
50-year low Jeff Michael thank you very
much